So, I want to take up in March at the 22nd 1908.
The State of Louisa is a state of continuous prayer and sacrifice and union with God.
Continuing in my usual state, Louisa said, "I found myself outside of myself and I seemed
to see M and the other priests.
The M is my senior, that's the bishop."
Then a young man of divine beauty came and drew near me and gave me some food.
And I prayed him to share the food that he was giving with me, with M and the others.
So, drawing near M, he gave him a good share of it, saying to him, "I share my food with
you and you satisfy my hunger by giving me souls."
Now, the only way you can satisfy the Lord's hunger or give him a relief is to give him
souls, there's no other way.
So, he was pointing to the work which M wants to do and also exciting him strongly in his
interior by giving him impulses and inspirations.
Then he shared it with others.
In the meantime, a venerable lady came out and those who had received food from the young
man drew around her and asked her what my state was.
Now, this is the bishop and the priests are asking this lady what state Louisa is in.
In other words, they are looking for a discernment.
They have to make a decision because they represent the church.
And the lady answered, "The state of this soul is a state of continuous prayer.
It's a state of sacrifice and of union with God."
So, three things.
And while being in this state, she is exposed to all the events of the church of the world
and of the justice of God.
Why?
Because she offered herself as a victim's soul to God's justice.
And she spends her time praying, repairing, disarming the justice and preventing chastisements
as much as she can.
So that's the way things are all suspended.
On hearing this, Louisa said, "I'm so bad."
And yet they say this is my state.
But in spite of this, I found myself near a little window up high.
And from it, I could see all that was being done in the church.
Now, if a person is called to the position that Louisa is in, it's never for yourself.
If the Lord calls you to union with God, it's never just for yourself.
It is that you will become a window for him to save souls.
You become a channel for him.
Okay, it's never just for yourself.
Let's put it this way.
You never become a teacher just for yourself, to you.
You never become a musician just for yourself.
It wouldn't make any sense, would it?
You never become a nurse or a doctor just for yourself.
You never become a mother or a father just for yourself.
That wouldn't make any sense, would it?
So neither does it make sense that you enter into a life of union with God and that you
don't have a role in bringing souls to the Lord.
It just doesn't make sense.
So when somebody is called deeply into union with God, the Lord gives them vision.
Now by vision, I don't mean a vision.
I don't mean a picture or an experience.
They become a seer, S-E-E-R is what they called it in the Old Testament.
That is a person who can see through the future and they can tell what the future is saying.
That is Isaiah 46-10, Isaiah 46-10, that the Lord reveals the future to his prophets.
So Amos 3-7, I've given you Amos 3-7 a number of times, haven't I?
So in this little window up high, could you only get it in this high state of union with
God?
You don't get it in the lower states.
There are lots of people at a very early stage of relationship with God and charismatic
prayer groups who claim to get all kinds of visions and revelations and stuff, but you
can claim a lot.
So from it she said, I could see all that was going on in the church and in the world.
And that's what the Lord said was happening for her.
And I could see the scourges that were about to fall.
These are the chastisements she tries to stop.
But who can tell them all, I move on so as not to be too long.
Oh, she said how I moaned and prayed.
I would have wanted to tear myself to pieces to prevent all this.
That's exactly what the priests were told.
But all of a sudden everything disappeared and I found myself inside of myself.
So Martha 25th, 1908 is a very important message and it's about discernment.
Continuing my usual state, blessed Jesus came for just a little and he told me, my daughter,
temptations can be conquered easily.
I think you should underline that one shouldn't you?
Because the devil is the most cowardly creature that can exist.
And a contrary act, a contempt, a prayer, are enough to make them flee.
Is that, is that fantastic?
Now a contempt is, excuse my language, get it hell out of here.
That's a contempt.
Well, you're telling him where to go.
That's where he belongs.
That's why I said, excuse my language.
Because we don't use it in this context, which is the only context in which it should
be used.
In other words, telling the devil to go to hell.
Okay, sorry.
He says a contempt, so I illustrated that, a prayer you don't need illustrated.
He said these are enough to make them flee.
In other words, it's actually very easy.
In fact, he said these acts render him even more cowardly than he is.
And in order not to bear that confusion, as soon as he sees the soul resolute and not
wanting to pay attention to his cowardice, he flees terrified.
He's terrified of anybody who will be faithful to God.
So the Lord is telling us we don't have too much excuses for giving in to temptations,
isn't that it?
Now, if the soul cannot easily free herself, it means that it is not only a temptation but
a passion rooted within the soul, and that means that there's something inside of us
that wants this thing.
That's a different matter altogether.
A temptation is something that comes from outside.
But if it has a root inside, then you're in trouble.
And this root tyrannizes her together with the temptation, therefore she's unable to
free herself, and where there is passion, the devil has more strength to make fun.
Isn't that strange?
Very important information there.
And that is we've been told from Volume 1, this is Volume 8, that we are to take ourselves
on, that we're to push the ego aside, that we're to deal with sin, that we're to have
mortification in our lives, and therefore this problem should be less and less and less and
less.
Otherwise, the divine will can't take over, because the divine will won't take over
where the passions are ruling.
You know the scripture for that, don't you?
Hebrews 12, 14, nothing unholy or unworthy can enter the presence of God.
And the spirituality of the divine will is the highest spirituality offered to the human
race.
So we can't insult God by holding on to stuff.
We've got to get rid of anything that even remotely shadows sin.
So Mark 29, 1908, peaceful souls are the delight of God.
Why?
Because God is peace, Jesus is the king of peace, and when Jesus was born, he offered
peace to anyone who had good willed, do you remember?
So this morning on coming, blessed Jesus seemed to carry a black mantle.
And drawing near me, he seemed to place me under it, saying, "In this way, I will envelop
all creatures as within a black mantle, and he disappeared."
Now we have to find out why it's black.
"I remain concerned because of some chastisement," she said.
And I prayed him to come back, for I could no longer be without him.
But I was as though bothered by that sight before.
Then after much hardship, he came carrying a cup filled with some liquor.
Liqueurs.
Now would you say?
He gave me some to drink.
Now she says elsewhere that she calls it a liqueur, but she doesn't know how it is.
In other words, to her it looks like that.
He gave me some to drink, and then he added my daughter, "Peaceful souls eat at my table
and drink from my copy, can't drink at a cup, can you?"
And the divine archer does nothing but dart through them continuously, and no dart is
wasted.
They are darts of love, okay?
All of them wound the loving soul and the soul feints, while the divine archer continues
with his arrows, which now make her die of love, and then bring her back to life of love.
That's in the Song of Songs, chapter 2, verses 1 to 7.
He brings me to his banqueting table, and his banner over me is loved, you remember?
We sing it, don't we?
Song of Songs, chapter 2, verses 1 to 7.
And from her wounds the soul shoots her darts, sorry, to wound the one who has so much wound
at her.
So a peaceful soul is the delight and the enjoyment of God.
You don't say amusement.
Amusement for us is a very negative word, isn't it?
The joy of God.
While we're turbid souls, these are the ones all disturbed and have all kinds of problems
and roots of passions and everything in them.
If the divine archer darts through them, the darts are wasted by the soul, leaving him
embittered and forming the diabolical amusement.
Now you can use the word amusement, can you see that?
So I want to give you Philippians 3, verses 12 to 16.
So we come to April the 5th, 1908, I have a VIP on this one, here the Blessed Mother
tells us what she understands sanctity is.
I think we should listen to her, what do you think?
So continue in my usual state, I found myself outside of myself within a garden in which
I could see the queen mother placed on a very high throne.
Now when she says a very high throne, she means something very close to God.
Because in the higher volumes, Louisa is actually taken into heaven and she says to the Lord,
I see the saints and I see the angels, but I don't see our blessed mother.
Here is she, surely she's in heaven.
And he said, ah come.
And she said that she had to go very very deeply into the blessed Trinity before she
could even see Blessed Mother, before she could even see her.
So a very high throne means way way up and beyond any of the angels or the saints.
It doesn't mean just a high throne over Louisa, do you know what I mean?
I yearnched to go up there and kiss her hand and as I tried to go, she came to meet me.
Why?
Because she's the humblest woman on earth.
Giving me a smacking kiss on my face, it's very interesting isn't it?
In looking at her, I saw as though a globe of light in her interior.
Now that globe of light is the divine will, okay?
So I saw a globe of light in her interior and within that light there was the word fiat.
Or fiat joined to God's fiat.
From that word descended many different on ending seas of virtues, grace, greatness, glory,
joys, beauty and everything that our Queen Mother contains as a whole.
Everything was rooted in that fiat.
And all of her goods took their origin from the fiat, omnipotent fertile holy fiat.
You can understand you, I feel mute, it is so great that I can say nothing and therefore
I stop here.
Now there's something vitally important there for us.
And that is that Louisa saw that everything, everything that the blessed Mother had in terms
of holiness and sanctity and gifts and everything came from her fiat.
It will be the same with us.
The more we say yes to the Lord, the more we give our fiat, the more He is able to rule
in our lives and the more He's able to pour out His gifts in us.
It's not told to us to tell us that she's an exalted being.
It's told to us to tell us that the fiat makes this difference in our lives.
So Louisa said, I looked at her with amazement and she said to me, my daughter, all of my
sanctity came out from within the word fiat.
There you have it, I did not move even one breath, one step, one action or anything at
all if not within the will of God.
My life, my food, my all was the will of God.
And this produced such sanctity, riches, glories, honors for me, not human ones now, but divine,
because the divine will gives you all the divine stuff.
So this is for us.
The more the soul is united, identified with the will of God.
So notice the union first and then the identification.
The more she can be called holy and she is loved more by God.
So what is the definition of holiness, it is living in the will of God.
Now for people who are not in the divine will, it's doing the will of God with as much love
and humility as possible.
When you want to live in the divine will, it's living in the divine will.
And the more she is loved, the more she is favored with God's gifts and graces because
her life is nothing but the product of the will of God.
How can he not love her if she is his own thing?
Therefore, one must not look at how much or how little he does, but rather whether it
is wanted by God.
Now that should be colored.
Because whether we like it or not, influenced by the world's thinking, the world is all
around us.
And so the world says such and such a thing is a big project or that's a small project.
That's a big thing or that's a small thing.
That's a big action or a small action.
And these writings Jesus tells us, no, something is big if it is done with the will of God and
in the will of God and because it's the will of God.
And it reaches its fullness when you do that with love and humility.
That's the height of sanctity.
That's it, you've arrived.
And so that's why we have to try and do it all the time.
So in fact, the Lord looks more at something little if it is according to his will than
at something great without it.
That means that the smallest actions in our lives can be sanctified in a most extraordinary
way.
So that passage there about our lady explaining holiness I think is vital.
So April the 8th in 1908 is also a VIP message about discernment.
I was concerned because I wasn't able to receive Holy Communion.
This is very important.
And good Jesus on coming told me, my daughter, I do not want you to be bothered by any thing
with your which you put a circle around the any thing.
And we say, I would go into my house is different.
He says, any thing, is that okay?
Now it's true that having communion is a great thing.
But how long does the tight union, I love the way the expression is the tight union with
the soul last at last quarter of an hour at the most.
Well the thing you should cherish the most is the complete undoing of your will.
Now that is, excuse me, that's our motto in divine will, not my will but thine be done.
Okay.
And if you're like any of the rest of us, you tell the Lord, you give me your will and
then you find yourself doing your own will, you know.
So we have to keep on giving it all the time.
The complete undoing of your will in mind because for one who lives in my will, there
is tight union, not only for a quarter of an hour but always, always.
My will is continuous communion with the soul.
So not once a day, but every hour and every moment is always communion for one who does
my will.
Now you see it.
But he wants is the 24/7, 365, that's what he wants.
Any lover would want that, wouldn't he?
So Louisa says, I've gone through the most bitter days because of the privation of my
highest good, thinking and fearing that my state might be a pretense.
Being in bed, this is very interesting because this is the first time she actually does the
reflection that I would have done on day two of her life.
Being in bed without movement, without occupation until the coming of the confessor.
And without that usual doziness, that means that she's going into deep prayer and ecstasy.
Tormented me and martyred me so much to the extent of making me fall ill for the pain
and the continuous tears.
She's bored, silly, she's dying of tedium, wouldn't you?
I'd get a nervous breakdown.
So more than once I begged the confessor to give me permission and obedience to sit on
the bed according to my habit.
In other words, not actually be in bed.
And to do my work of Tambolo, she used to do embroidery.
I don't know why they call it Tambolo, I just don't know.
If I were not dozy and if Jesus Christ had not pleased to let me share as a victim, you
have to say a victim soul because we have a different meaning nowadays to victim.
So if you did not let me share as a victim soul in one of the mysteries of his passion.
But he continuously and absolutely prohibited it to me.
So the priestess will not allow it.
Rather he added, this is very, very interesting now, the priestess Father Janaro di Janaro.
He added that this state of mine, although I was deprived of my highest good, was to
be considered as a state of victim soul because of the violence and the pain of the privation
itself and of the obedience.
This means the priest has got the message at long last, Louisa hasn't.
Now she's been asking time out of number why I have all this privation and all the rest
of it.
And surely if I don't have Jesus coming all the time and I don't have these things happening,
surely I've got to get back to work and all the rest of it.
The priest said no, everything in your life is part of being a victim soul.
Let me give it to you in a different example.
If you're married and you have a family, whether you're sick or well, old or young, dying or
otherwise, you're still married.
In other words, no matter what happens to you in that state of life, the state of life
is that you're married and have a family.
Does that make sense?
So he's saying to her, no matter what happens to you, whether Jesus is coming or not coming,
whether you're having a privation or you're having this or that, it's still a state of
victim and that is correct.
So he has given her, the priest has given her the discernment at long last.
And so what I've done there is put a VIP on that sentence.
She got her answer from the priest and that's what the Lord wanted.
That doesn't mean that Louisa won't have problems about it.
I always obey it, she said, but the Martin of my heart was constantly saying to me, isn't
this a pretense, where is your doziness, where is your state of victim and what do you suffer
of the mysteries of the passion?
Because she doesn't need a devil, does she?
No, who's tempting her?
Herself.
And what the Lord is illustrating for us is that we are the cause of most of our own problems.
We even say that about one another, Stapman, he's own worst enemies or something like
that.
Okay.
And he says to herself, get up, get up, don't make pretenses, work, work.
Don't you see that this pretense will lead to your damnation?
And you, don't you tremble, don't you think of the terrible judgment of God, don't you
see that after so many years, she's lashing herself, isn't she?
That you've done nothing but dig your own abyss from which you will never get out for
all eternity.
Oh God, who can say the ripping of my heart and the cruel sufferings that tormented my
soul, crushing me and throwing me into a sea of pain, but darling, you brought it on yourself.
The devil wouldn't do better, would he?
But tyrant obedience did not even allow one atom of my will, now this is volume eight.
I don't know if you remember volumes one and two where Jesus taught her about obedience
and told her that the purpose of obedience is to destroy yourself will.
That was the very reason why communities gathered together and took vows of obedience so that
they could grow in holiness quicker than not having them.
Okay.
And of course it's only when you're told to do something you don't want to do, or at
a time you don't want to do it, that you realize just what you've brought on yourself, the tyrant
of obedience.
May the divine will be done which disposes this way.
So while in the midst of these cruel torments last night, as I was in my usual state, uh-huh,
her usual state now is this ecstasy, this what she calls her doziness, okay?
I found myself surrounded by some people who were saying recite a pat or Ave and Gloria
in honor of Saint Francis of Paola.
No, I don't know that Saint, who will bring you some refreshment for your sufferings.
So she recited the three prayers and she said, as I did so, the saint appeared bringing me
a little loaf of bread and he gave it to me saying eat it.
Now, don't forget this is spiritual food, okay?
I ate it and felt all strengthened because it's spiritual strength is what she actually
needs.
And then I said to him, dear Saint, I would like to tell you something and he all kindness
said to me, what would you like to say?
And Louisa said, I fear very much that my state may not be the will of God.
Listen.
And she can't get Jesus to listen to all of this because Jesus tells her rather quickly,
it is my will, but she still has to go round the roundabouts.
Have you ever tried to tell something simple to her person, but they are so determined
to give you all the nitty gritty and to give you all the minutest details that even though
you gave him the answer and the first line, you're going to have to listen for the next
half hour, that's never happened to you, isn't it?
And sometimes they do it on the phone and you want to put the phone as far out from your
ear as possible.
So since Jesus won't listen to her, she gets the saint to listen to her.
I think that's rather interesting.
So she said, listen, in the first years, it's going to turn the whole story.
In the first years of this illness which occurred at intervals, I would feel our Lord calling
me to become a victim.
At the same time, I would be caught by internal sufferings and wounds such that externally
it appeared as if I was having a fit.
It's rather interesting because that's the first time she's explained that.
Now I fear that it was my fantasy that produced these evils.
The saint said, the sure sign to know whether a state is the will of God is that the soul
is ready to do otherwise, which Louisa always was.
But she knew that the will of God was no longer that state.
In other words, you're not attached to it.
Not persuaded Louisa added, but dear saint, I've not told you everything.
You see, he's got to get the nitty gritty.
Listen, he has to hear the confession.
The first ones were at intervals and then from the time when our Lord called me to continuous
immolation, it's 23, 21 years since I've always been in bed.
And who can tell my tribulations?
Sometimes it seems that he leaves me.
He takes suffering away from me, the only one and faithful friend of my state.
That's my state of victim.
And I remain crushed without God and even without the support of suffering.
And so doubts and fears that my state will not be the will of God comes in.
And so the saint, all sweetness said to her, "I repeat to you."
He's given her the answer, you see, which is not satisfied with it.
And she wasn't satisfied with any of the answers that Jesus gave her either.
"I repeat to you what I've said to you before.
If you are ready to do the will of God, if you knew it, then your state is his will."
Now, I very much feel within my soul that if I knew the will of God with all clarity,
that Jesus is told her endlessly, I would be ready to follow this holy volition at the
cost of my life.
So I remained more tranquil.
May the Lord be always praised.
I'm sure the saint heave decided relief going back to heaven.
So May the 3rd, 1908.
Now I love incidents like that because it shows you at Louise at much more like us.
Yes, very human.
Whereas if we saw her heroic up here all the time, willing all the time to take whatever
came and not questioning anything, I wouldn't have any interest in her, to be honest with
you.
Because I'd say there's no connection with us.
It's when she's struggling and being a bit silly like this, and I say, "Oh, yeah, it's
all right."
I can communicate with someone like this.
And I think it's wonderful.
Very few saints have been great enough to tell you their faults.
In the Bible we only had two, and that was Jeremiah and Paul, who they only two.
I mean, Jesus didn't have any, so he couldn't give us any.
But it takes somebody very great to actually tell you their struggles and their faults.
The rest of us try to put on the best view we have, and we try to let everybody think
we're grand.
Thanks, we're not having any struggles, thank you very much, and all the rest of us.
That's not the reality, is it?
Everybody's struggling about something.
So May the 3rd, 1908, the effects of the circulation of the divine will and the soul.
So in other words, what does the divine will do inside of us?
Continuing in my usual state, I felt our Lord near me for just a little, and he told me,
my daughter, with the soul who does my will, my will circulates in her whole being like
blood.
Now, he's using the image of blood, because we've got thousands of miles of blood vessels
running all over our whole being.
And the blood takes life to every part of our body, so that's why he's using that image.
So she's in continuous contact with me, with my power, with my wisdom, my charity and beauty.
So if we're in contact with that, then these attributes of God will be applied to us in
so far as we can take them.
And she takes part in all that is mine.
As she no longer lives of her own volition, her will lives in mine.
And as mine circulates in hers, hers, her will circulates in all of my being.
Isn't that incredible?
And this is why Louisa can have such squabbles with Jesus.
She's actually inside of him, and he's inside of her.
She circulates in all of my being, and I feel her continuous contact.
You see, this can only happen if there's no sin.
If there's sin, this is not going to happen.
The divine will won't be circulating around us.
And as I feel touched by her continuously, you cannot understand how drawn I feel to love
her, to favor her, to answer her in everything she asks.
If I denied it, I would deny it to myself.
Besides, all things considered, since she lives in my will, she asks for nothing but for what
I myself want.
This is what she wants, and this alone makes her happy, makes her happy for herself and
for others, because her life is more in heaven than on earth.
This is the fruit that my will produces to beatify the soul in advance.
I don't know if you color it, you should.
That's the whole thing that the Lord wants to beatify us ahead of time, that you live
heaven on earth.
So May the 12th, 1908, we now have how the bad rich are destroying the poor.
It's a bit unusual as one of these messages.
Continuing my usual state, I was praying to our Lord that he would concede to put peace
in the hearts of people.
They're all in discord, and she said, "The poor want to attack the rich."
There is so much turmoil, and there's a thirst for human blood.
It seems that they themselves can no longer contain themselves.
Now I want to give you Luke 16, do you remember the story of Devas and Lazarus?
Yeah, that's what you're talking about here.
Luke 16, Devas and Lazarus, yeah.
It seems that they themselves can no longer contain themselves.
If the Lord does not put his hand in, we are already close to the chastisements, which
many times he has manifested.
Then Jesus came for just a little and told me, "My daughter, a just justice is mine."
It's very interesting, because we think of justice as punishment.
We don't think of it as right and proper, if I can put it that way, okay?
Now watch this.
The rich have been the first to give a bad example to the poor.
They are the first to move away from religion, that's true, isn't it?
They are the first to go from fulfilling their duties to the point of feeling ashamed
even to enter a church to attend Mass and perform their obligation.
The poor have nourished themselves with the poisonous slubber of the rich, okay?
And have fed themselves well with the poison of their bad example.
And with that same poison given to them, unable to contain it, they try to attack them and
even to kill them.
There's no order without subjection, that's very, very interesting.
In other words, if you are going to have any kind of a society starting with the family
and with any grouping of human beings up to the government, there must be leaders and
there must be people who accept the laws, okay?
That's what he means, there's no order without subjection.
That means obedience to the law.
And the people rebel against God against the rich, oh sorry, the rich have subtracted
themselves from God, I see the rich is running the world, isn't it?
And so the people rebel against God, they rebel against the rich and against everyone.
The scale of my justice is full, I can no longer contain it.
So I want to give you the letter of James chapter 5 from verse 1, where he tells the rich to
watch out, you know, that the Lord is going to chapter 5 from verse 1.
So May the 15th, 1908, she sees wars and revolutions, again I want to give you Isaiah 46, 10 and
Amos 3, 7 that the Lord shows everything to the prophets ahead of time, 3, 7.
As I was in my usual state, I found myself outside of myself in the midst of revolutions.
It seems that they are ever more obstinate in wanting to shed blood.
You see, it's 1908 and they're building up to World War I, that's what she's seeing.
And you see, around the world leading up to World War I, there were all kinds of wars.
There was the war war in South Africa and there was wars in different places around the world.
So she sees this, that's what she means by wars and revolutions actually going on.
I prayed to the Lord and he told me, my daughter, men are preparing two storms, I've just given
you that in English as distinct from the way it's written.
One against the government and the other against the church.
We would say two revolutions or two attacks, he said two storms.
In the meantime, I seem to see fleeing leaders, the king at risk of being taken a prisoner,
past the king of Italy, and she'll tell you more about him as well.
Because when they actually kill him, she's allowed to go to purple tree to do some reparation
for him.
So the king of Italy at risk of being taken a prisoner and trying to flee.
I cannot say it well, it seemed that he was falling into the hands of his enemies, which
he did.
All the rich were undergoing grave dangers and some were dying.
If you remember the French Revolution, it was the poor against the rich.
And you see, if it gets to that kind of stage, it's usually very vicious.
That which was most sorrowful is that among the leaders of the revolutions, also against
the church were priests.
Now why would that be?
That they would have fallen already for Freemasonry or a Marxist communism.
Because the Marxist communism was, atheistic materialism was foisted on the world by the
French Revolution.
And then by the 1900s then, it turned into Marxist communism.
And then Freemasonry was there for hundreds of years before that.
And when they combined, it was deadly.
So you're talking about perverted clergy.
Another piece of language for that, of course, is Judas's.
Then when things were reaching the extreme excesses, a foreign power seems to intervene.
Okay.
And the foreign power, World War I, they all get mixed up.
I won't continue any further, she said.
So June the 22nd, 1908, the divine will triumphs over everything.
Okay.
This June the 22nd.
This morning, Louisa said, "I was feeling very oppressed because of the privation of
my adorable Jesus.
And I said to myself, 'I cannot take any more.
How can I go on without my life?
What patience it takes with you, Jesus?"
She said that to him a number of times.
What would be the power that would induce him to come?
At that moment he came and he told me, "My daughter, the power that triumphs over everything,
that conquers everything, that levels everything, that sweetens everything, is the will of God."
It's a total solution to everything because it contains such power that nothing can resist
it, okay?
And then he goes on to say that it transforms everything it's allowed to touch.
While he was saying this, "A road full of rocks, thorns, and steep mountains appeared
before me."
So that seems to be like Isaiah 40 verses 1 to 10.
Once all of this was placed in the will of God, by the power of it the rocks were pulverized,
the thorns were changed into flowers and the mountains leveled.
That means that when the will of God is allowed to work with us, the rocks that are in us
are pulverized, the thorns that sting are changed into flowers, and the mountains of
pride and self-glory and all the rest, they're all leveled.
That's the work that the divine will does in us.
So in the will of God, all things have the same appearance.
They all assume the same color.
So Isaiah 40 said to bring down the mountains and fill up the valleys so that the king can
actually enter.
Now the king is divine will, coming to his own kingdom inside of each one of us.
Who she said, "May his holy will be blessed."
Now between that message and the next one, the next one is June 31, 1908.
Now on the 30th of June 1908 an asteroid crashed into Siberia and devastated about 2,000 square
kilometers of land.
If it had landed in a populated area, millions of people would have died instantly.
Siberia.
Yeah, you can check this on the internet.
Yeah, but the thing I want to tell you is, think of Louisa.
She is doing all of this suffering and intercession and all the rest of it, and she doesn't realize,
she doesn't take into account what she has prevented from happening.
Now the Lord is going to remind her.
You keep on saying that you're not getting enough, you don't realize what has, you've
actually provided.
And it's just that I just happen to have that piece of information.
And it's in between these two messages where she has seen the wars and the revolutions
and everything else, and the, yeah, but also her sufferings.
You see, it's not just her prayers.
Just without sufferings, I haven't got too much value.
It's called hot air.
I didn't say that, I said, no, I said something very specific, prayers without sufferings have
very little value.
It's very easy to say Hail Mary and you don't give a top any damn about the people.
I get so upset and at Sunday Mass that I have to try and shut off from it.
They say, all kinds of prayers, Lord, here is Lord, graciously, here is Lord, here is
Lord, graciously, here is.
And they're not going to do a thing about anything they're saying.
And they're making the most wonderful prayers, I say, but it's only hot air.
Whereas if you were prepared to fast and pray and do something about it, and then you say
the exact same prayer, it would change things.
Is that okay?
Yeah.
So it has a huge difference between something that simply comes from the lips and something
that comes from your innermost being.
Now, Luisa was praying from her innermost being.
She was suffering the passion and if she wasn't suffering that, she was suffering this martyrdom
of the privation of Jesus, and she was offering it all.
And I think that was one of the results because he tells her after a while, you don't seem
to take into account what you have prevented from happening because that asteroid, if it
had hit London, would have destroyed everything inside.
Just to give one example, that's close by.
Okay.
So June 31, 1908, we're going to talk about love and we're going to talk about the rich
and the poor again.
So that Luke 16, 19 to 31, Tives and Lazarus, rich man, poor man.
I want to give you Matthew 26, 11.
I want to give you two Corinthians eight, nine.
So it's about the true spirit of charity.
In other words, you can hand out money and there's no charity.
Continue in my usual state full of bitterness and of privations.
After much hardship, I seem to see people in the act of rebelling and of intensifying
the brawl against the rich.
In the meantime, the lament of most sweet Jesus made itself heard in my ear, all embittered
saying, "I am the one who is giving freedom to the
poor.
I'm tired of the rich."
In other words, I'm allowing the poor to rebel.
They have done enough.
How much money are wasted on balls, on theatricals, on useless trips, on vanities and even on
sins?
Oh, boys, wouldn't that condemn an awful lot of people?
So I want to give you Luke 14, 13.
And Luke 18 from verse 22.
You see, modern society thinks you should be wasting your money on balls and theatricals
and useless trips and pagan festivals in honor of a saint and everything.
And the poor, he said, they could not have enough bread to satisfy their hunger.
They were oppressed, weary and embittered.
Had they given them only, if the rich had given them only what they spent on unnecessary
things, my poor would have been happy.
That's exactly the story of divas and Lazarus, the scraps the rich man's table.
But the rich have kept them like a family who did not belong to them, and even more,
they've despised them.
Giving comforts and amusements for themselves as things befitting their condition, and leaving
the poor in misery as something befitting their condition.
Okay, so I want to give you Galatians 2, 10, and I want to give you the letter of James
chapter 2 verses 1 to 13, because I gave you James 5 before, 2 1 to 13.
There's an awful lot in the New Testament about the rich and the poor.
So while saying this, Jesus seemed to withdraw grace from the poor, what's that grace?
It's the grace of Lazarus to be able to put up with it and still trust in God and die
in poverty.
Okay, that's the grace.
He seemed to withdraw grace from the poor, and these would become enraged against the
rich.
That's exactly what happened in the French Revolution, in such a way that grave things
would happen.
On seeing this, Louisa said, "My dear life and my all good, it's true that there are
some bad rich people, but there are also some good ones."
Watch this now, she's throwing herself unknowingly from the flying pan into the fire.
Okay.
"Like the many devout ladies who give arms in the churches and the priests who do good
for all, oh Lord, will you hear Jesus' response?"
I won't be good for you to hear his response.
"And my daughter," he said, "keep quiet and don't touch this key so very sorrowful to
me."
I could say that I do not recognize these devout ladies.
Whoops, Matthew 7, 21-23, "Lord, did we not prophesy in your name and work mighty miracles
in your name?"
And he said, "I don't even know you."
Okay.
What are these devout ladies doing?
They give arms where they want to obtain their intent and to hold people at their service.
Whoops, wrong motivation.
They spend even thousands of lire for those who sympathize with them.
And then where it is necessary, they do not aim to give a cent.
Could I say that they do it for me?
Could I recognize these actions of theirs?
Do yourself can recognize whether they do it for me from these signs if they are ready
for any bare necessity, okay?
Sorry.
If they are ready for any bare necessity, they do not differentiate by giving much where
it is not necessary and refusing to give little where it is necessary.
One can say that there's no spirit of true charity.
Now this is the eighth volume you've read, okay?
So you know for absolute certainty that Jesus says if your actions are not done out of love
for him, they have no value.
They are not recognized, forget about it.
You can give three million and it doesn't mean a thing to him.
But if you give the widows might out of pure love, yeah, he'll look at it, okay.
So he says there's no spirit of true charity or upright operating or working there.
So my poor are put into oblivion also by these devout ladies.
I would like to have been one of them devout ladies, would you?
So now what about the priests?
Oh holy God.
Am I daughter?
That's even worse, he said.
They do good to all, that's what Louisa had said of above, you see, you deceive yourself.
They do good to the rich.
They've time for the rich.
By them also the poor are almost excluded.
For the poor they've no time.
For the poor they've not a word of comfort or help to tell them.
They send them away reaching the point of pretending they're ill.
I could say that if the poor have moved away from the sacraments the priests have contributed
to this because they've always taken their time to confess them and others, they don't
want to hear their confessions.
That's James chapter two verses one to nine, nearly verbatim and the poor grew tired and
so they didn't come back.
But then if a rich person should show up, oops that's James 5.5, literally James 5.5.
But if a rich person would show up, oh it's all the opposite, they wouldn't hesitate one
instant time, words, comforts, help, they would find anything for the rich.
Could I say that the priests have a spirit of true charity if they reach the point of
picking the ones to whom they should listen, and what about the others?
They either send them somewhere else or oppress them so much that if my grace did not help
the poor in a special way, the poor would have been banished from my church.
Isn't that something else?
True charity and upright spirit only rarely do some priests have them.
Isn't that absolutely scary?
But as for the rest, I'd say that these have departed from the earth.
So Louisa wasn't impressed by that.
So let's come to, that's quite something isn't it?
It's very frightening because you're being told so clearly that if the right motivation
isn't there, forget about it, God doesn't want to know, God doesn't want, and it can
appear that you are doing the right thing, the appearance isn't right.
So July the 26th, 1908 is just a sentence or two.
Louisa said, Jesus told her, "My daughter, obedience is the ark of my dwelling in the
soul, where this ark of obedience is not present, I can say, there's no place for me in that
soul and I'm forced to remain outside."
So if we're doing our own will, we're doing self-will, there's no room for him, it's
actually quite simple.
So August the 10th, 1908, we come back again to love.
He keeps coming back because this is a central point and I want to give you a little heading
for it.
Absence makes the heart grow funder.
You know what, don't you?
Continuing my usual state with full of bitterness and of privations, after I received communion,
I was lamenting to blessed Jesus about the way he had left me and about the uselessness
of my state.
And he, having compassion on my lament, told me, "My daughter, nothing has diminished the
goods that exist between you and me because the whole of good is in its origin, the origin
of its foundation."
Okay?
So it's where it started from that makes something really good or not good.
We would say, "If the roots are rotten, forget about the plant.
If the roots are healthy, you'll have a healthy plant."
So the origin of the relationship between Louisa and Jesus is the divine will.
When two persons unite themselves with the bond of friendship or with the bond of marriage
and they've exchanged gifts besides and have loved each other so much as to become inseparable
to the extent that one has taken and copied the other so much as to feel the being of
the beloved within herself.
If out of bare necessity they are forced to be away from each other, are these gifts perhaps
diminished or does their love decrease, not at all?
On the contrary, being far away makes them grow more in love.
That's why I gave you the heading and keeps the gifts received with greater care waiting
for some greater unexpected gift at the return of the other one.
But there's more.
Since one has copied her beloved within herself, this is talking about the Lord and the soul,
it seems that there's no distance for her because she feels the voice of the beloved
flow within her voice, having imitated him.
She feels him flow in her mind, in her works and in her steps.
This is one of the prayers we have in the divine will, that the divine will would flow
in your mind and in your voice and absolutely everything.
So he is far, but he is near.
She looks at him and he escapes her.
He touches her, but she can't grasp him.
That's John 20, do you remember Mary of Magdalene, verses 1 to 10?
So she clung to his feet and he said, "No, don't cling."
So she touches him, but cannot clasp him.
Therefore, the soul is in continuous martyrdom of love, reaching out and yet you can't grasp.
That's only while we're on earth.
Now if justice forces me to deprive you of me and to be far away for some time, he's
been telling her this for eight volumes, "Can you say that I have taken the gifts away
from you and that there's a diminution of love?"
And Louisa doesn't answer that and she says, "Lord, my state is too difficult.
My dear life, and what am I here if you do not let me suffer to spare my neighbor, the
chastisements?"
You've said many times that you would not allow rain and it's not raining.
So I cannot beat you in anything.
Look at the problem.
Whatever you say you do, while if I had you near me like before, I would tell you so much
that you would let me win.
Now this is the problem and it's very, very interesting.
It's the problem of the victim's soul, that if he stays away from her and leaves her in
the agony of the privations, she's not in a position to be able to get around him, to
give her the sufferings and therefore to mitigate the chastisements.
She calls that winning and if he stays away and leaves her in this agony as we've been
reading for the past couple of messages, then it means he wins because he says, "I'll do
this and you do it."
I just love the way she says it.
I think it's beautiful, you know.
She said, "How can you say the distance is nothing?"
You know.
She's not agreeing with him at all.
And so he said, "It's precisely because of this that I am forced to be far away, so
it's not to let you win and to give course to justice."
However, by keeping you here, there is also some good because the lack of water will
call for famine and during this time, the people will be humiliated and after the slaughters
and the wars have taken place, grace will find them more disposed to be saved.
Is this not also a good?
And while wars were about to overtake the famine, by keeping you here, it will be postponed
a little longer and more souls will be saved.
He does win and he knows how to win, doesn't he?
Okay.
Go back to the line where it says, "During the famine, people will have to be humiliated
and they might grow."
Inside that, put Isaiah chapter 2 verses 7, 9 and 11.
That's where Paul, where Isaiah says that the pride of man has to be brought low if
God has to be able to work because pride is the big barrier between us and God.
And then he added, "Love never says enough."
Even if love scourged the soul and tore her to pieces, those pieces would cry out love.
Love never says enough.
It's not yet content.
It pulverizes those pieces.
It reduces them to nothing and in that nothing, it blows its fire and gives its own shape.
It mixes nothing human but only divine, you see, the Lord has to bring down our pride into
nothingness, okay?
And it's only with the nothingness that he can work because he won't mix the human with
the divine.
It just doesn't mix.
It's like iron and water won't mix.
And it's then that love sings its glories, its braveries and its prejudice saying, "I
am content, my love has won, it has destroyed the human and built the divine."
That is what is going on.
And the Lord says, "That is the incredible mystery that's going on inside of each one
of us, that the human has to be brought down so that the divine can be built up."
And when the human has truly been brought down into nothingness and the divine therefore
has taken over, then the divine will has won, but also love has won and the person is completely
redeemed.
And Jesus says in higher volumes that, "Once the will has been given to him, nothing more
will be asked because there is nothing else to give.
Your will is your highest gift."
So he says, "It happens to love as to a talented artisan who, having many objects which are
not to his liking, he breaks them to pieces, puts them on the fire and keeps them there
until they melt, making them lose all their shape.
Think of Jeremiah and the potter in Jeremiah 18 verses 1 to 12.
Or think of me making candles and if I don't like the candle then he just melts it down
and he's jarred all over again.
So you put them back on the fire and they lose their shape and then he forms from them
other objects which are most beautiful and pleasant worthy of his talent.
It is true that for that which is human this action of love is so very hard.
Now love is a capital L1 John 4 7, God is love.
And I also want to give you Sam 1 4 5 verse 17.
God can only act out of love because that's what He is.
And yet this action of love which pulverizes what is human in us to let the divine take
over seems very, very hard almost like torture, martyrdom.
1 John 4 7, God is love.
So this action of love seems so very hard but when the soul sees her gain she will see
how beauty has taken the place of ugliness, richness of poverty, nobility of roughness
and she too will sing the glories of love.
So when will we sing the glories of love I think only in heaven because it's only then
that we will really see.
So August the 14th 1908 this is about the divine image.
Having received communion I could see the baby within my interior.
As though looking for something important and I said my pretty little one what are you looking
for which so much zeal and he said daughter I love that you see them as an infant and
he calls her daughter okay daughter I am looking for the brush of your will to be able
to portray my image Romans 829 to be able to portray my image in your heart.
In fact if you do not give me your will now Louise has long since given her will to him
this message is for us okay.
If you do not give me your will I lack the brush to be able to portray myself now I need
to give you Ephesians 210 because his thinking of himself is a painter okay and Ephesians
210 says your God's work of art created in Christ Jesus okay.
So if you don't give me your will he said I lack the brush to be able to portray myself
freely in you and just as your will serves as a brush in my hands love serves as colors
in order to impress the variety of colors of my image.
Now the colors are all the divine attributes love and joy and peace and patience and kindness
and all the rest of it and that's Galatians 520.
Moreover just as the human will serves as brush for me my will serves as a brush in the
hands of the soul in order to portray her image in my heart is that something else.
In me then she will find abundant color of love for the variety of colors.
That's all the work you do in the divine will is that fantastic.
So August the 19th 1908 the soul must so good with her whole being.
So for that I want to give you 2 Corinthians 9 6 and Galatians 6 7 to 8.
So having done my meditation on the fact that one who sows good will harvest good and one
who sows vices will harvest evils I was thinking about what good I could sow given my position
my misery and my inability.
At that moment I felt I was being harvested and I heard Jesus say in my interior the soul
was so good with her whole being with all of it.
The soul possesses a mental intelligence and she must apply it to understand God to think
of good alone never allowing any bad seed to enter her mind to Corinthians 10 5.
2 Corinthians 10 5 and Proverbs 23 7 Proverbs 23 7.
So the Lord said that we possess a mental intelligence and we must apply this to understanding
God and think of good alone and never allowing any bad seed to enter the mind.
And this is the sowing of good in the mind that's number 1.
So number 2 is the same with her mouth.
She must never sow any bad seed that is bad words unworthy of a Christian.
But always say holy, useful and good words.
So here is the sowing of good in the mouth.
Now I can't give you references for that, I just want to say to you there are 50 proverbs
on the tongue alone in the book of Proverbs there's 50 of them and one of them says there's
life and death in the power of the tongue and those who eat it must eat the fruit thereof.
So 50 proverbs on the tongue alone.
So number 3 then with her heart he said she must love God alone, that's Deuteronomy 6
4 to 10 you know that went off by heart now don't you?
And it's also that's Deuteronomy 6 4 to 10 and it's also Matthew 22, Matthew 22 verses
23 to 34, sorry to 24, 23 to 24.
So with her heart she must love God alone desire God palpitate for him and tend towards him.
Here is the sowing of good with the heart.
Then with her hands she must do holy works with her feet she must walk after the examples
of our Lord and so on.
On hearing this I thought to myself so in my position I too can that my position mean
I'm sitting here in bed and I can't do anything.
I too can sow good seed in spite of my extreme misery but I thought of this with a certain
fear on the account that the Master would ask of me that's in judgment whether I have
sown well and in my interior I heard Jesus repeat, my goodness is so great that great
wrong is done by those who make me known as severe, very demanding and rigorous.
Now the God who is severe demanding and rigorous is the God of Sinai, would you write that
beside it the God of Sinai and the reason why the God of Sinai had to be severe demanding
and rigorous is that he had to make a people and he had to try and get them from an absolutely
pagan way of life into living a disciplined life on his commandments and if you would
like to do that with Ireland today you'd know Moses is difficulty.
It was total miracle stuff to get an entire nation to turn around and live a completely
new way of life so that's why he had to be severe and demanding with the commandment
but Jesus came all merciful love so it's wrong for us to say that he's demanding and
severe because he actually paid the price for everything for us.
So what in the front they give to my love, that's Jesus incarnate.
I will ask for no other account but of the little field given to them and I will ask
for an account of nothing but to give them the fruit of their harvest.
In other words he wants to see what you have sown so he can give you the harvest.
I will give it to the intelligence, the more it has understood me in life the more it will
understand me in heaven that is a very very important point.
That's why the more we study these writings of Louisa and the more we read the scriptures
you enter heaven at a much deeper level than anybody else because the more you understand
him on entering heaven the further on you are.
You see there are souls who are dying and they're not ready at all and they're probably
not ready to scripture in their lives they probably don't know them at all and from the
way you hear people talking nowadays you realize they know nothing about God, they don't know
what he's like.
And so when they go to the other side they've got to start a wronger hane.
They don't know him.
And so they're being judged by someone they actually don't know which is really sad whereas
we will go to him in love and it is love that will be judging us.
So if love meets love you don't have a problem and since fire is the image of love, fire
is the image of God and fire is the image of judgment then a spark leaps into the fire.
Saint Therese of Lissia was asked would she be afraid of God's judgment and she said afraid.
She said I'll be sitting on his knee when he's judging the earth.
He's my dad.
He sees the difference between someone who knows him and someone who doesn't, the judging
the earth's thing is the people who are far out there and therefore are not responding
in any love towards him.
And so here's Jesus saying no I will want to give you your harvest.
So the more you understand me in life he said the more you will understand me in heaven.
And the more the soul will understand me the greater the joy and the attitude which they
will be inundated.
I want to give you the book of Daniel chapter 12, 1 to 3 where he says that the holy people
will shine like stars in the presence of God.
So to the mouth he said I will give the harvest of the different divine flavors and its voice
will harmonize above all the other blessed.
To the works I will give the harvest of my gifts and so on with all the rest.
So he's begging us not to misinterpret who he is.
So the next one is about discernment.
This is August the 23rd 1908.
Continue in my usual state.
I was very concerned about the state of my soul she's back to it again and I said to
myself who knows what evil there is in my soul that the Lord deprives me of him and leaves
me abandoned.
Now she knows why he's not coming.
At that moment Jesus came for just a little and filled all of myself with him and my whole
being was all directed to him.
And notice that he comes and he just absolutely takes her into his love so that everything
is enveloped in love.
There was not even a fiber or a motion that would not tend towards him she said.
Then afterwards he told me, "Have you seen my daughter?
The sign that there is guilt in the soul when she finds herself without me is that as I
return to let myself be seen she does not remain all filled with God."
Now Louisa could not have been enveloped completely by love if she had moved away from love.
Does that make sense?
So the fact that as soon as he returned she was able to be completely absorbed in his
love says that she hadn't moved.
The problem with us is that we can move away from the Lord because we're affected so much
by worldly influence.
And the worst influence we have is the television and what comes to us from mobile phones.
I think it's the worst of all, absolutely worldly thinking and pulling you away from
God completely.
So I think that the more we go into divine will the more control we have to take over
the black pucks.
So he said, "The sign by which the guilt of the soul would be is that she doesn't remain
in her God nor is her being immediately disposed to immerse herself completely in me in such
a way that not a fiber would be left which is not fixed in her Creator.
Whether there is guilt or something that is not completely mine, neither can I fill her."
So he's telling Louisa, "Listen, nothing has changed between you and me.
Nor can the soul immerse herself in me.
Guilt matter cannot enter into God.
Would you please call her there?"
You should bring a color pen every now and then.
And matter cannot enter into God nor can it run towards God.
I want to give you two references there.
One that you should know of by heart now, Hebrews 12, 14.
Nothing unholy or unworthy can enter the presence of God.
And I want to give you Isaiah 35 verses 8 to 10.
Where Isaiah is talking about the highway to God and he said only the redeemed will walk
on it, the unclean won't be on that path.
Okay.
So let me give you another one.
This is August the 26th, 1908 and it's talking about constant sale.
As I was in my usual state, I was all afflicted and almost dazed because of the usual privations.
And then Jesus came just in passing and he told me, "My daughter, that which I want you
to take to heart is the constancy in good."
That means that you continue day after day after day after day after day.
Both internal and external because the repetition of the act of loving me, of many interior
acts and of constant good makes divine life grow ever more in the soul.
Now, please, please put an NB beside that.
Make a big mark, make sure you see it.
It's one of the gems.
Let me read it again.
The repetition of the act of loving me, of many interior acts and of constant good is
what makes divine life grow ever more in the soul so you know how to do it.
But with such energy that she can be compared to a child who growing in good air and with
healthy foods keeps growing well in full health until he reaches his proper stature without
needing either doctors or medicines.
Even more, he's so robust and strong that he relieves and helps others.
In other words, full spiritual health here.
On the other hand, one who is not constant grows like a child who's not always fed with
healthy foods and lives in putrid air.
He grows sickly and since his members do not have the strength to develop and grow due
to the lack of good nourishment, they develop with defects.
And so, a tumor forms in one place and an abscess in another.
Isn't that rather interesting?
Here's a medical diagnosis you weren't expecting.
He walks with a limp, he speaks with difficulty, and one can say that he's a poor cripple.
Though one can see good members mixed in, those with defects are more.
And even though he consults doctors and takes medicines, they do him little good because
his blood is infected by the putrid air, the one thing they didn't look at.
And his members are weak and defective from malnutrition.
Gosh, we millions of children like that today, haven't we?
So he will be a man, but he will not reach proper stature and will always need help without
being able to help others.
Such is the inconsistent soul.
Now, what was wrong with this child?
First of all, it wasn't properly fed.
So if we're not feeding on the Lord's messages and we're not feeding on prayer and we're
not feeding on the scriptures and not feeding on the Eucharist, we're responsible for our
malnutrition.
Okay.
The other is the putrid air.
And the putrid air for me, spiritually, is that you're breathing the air of worldliness.
You see, the problem with Abraham's nephew, Lord, was that he liked Sodom and Gomorrah.
He wanted to benefit from the life that was there.
They were rich.
They had all kinds of luxuries and all the rest of it.
And he was living on the edge of it.
No, he wasn't right in the center of it, but he was benefiting from it.
And so when the angels came to try and get him and his wife and children out of the place,
the wife turned back.
Many people do that.
They want to be Christian, but they want all the benefits of the world as well.
I think that's one of the greatest sicknesses in the church today.
There's no detachment from the world.
The early Christians knew that they were the very special people of God and they were living
a heavenly life on earth, and they were able to change the earth into a heavenly place.
Now the world has invaded and evangelized us, and we have become worldly and sick.
Okay.
That's to me, that's the putrid air.
Such is the inconstant soul.
With inconstancy in good, it is as if the soul nourished herself with foods that are
not good, and by applying herself to other things which are not God, it is as if she breathed
putrid air.
So divine life grows with difficulty and purely because it lacks the strength and the vigor
of constancy.
So I'm going to leave it there for tonight.